you [ __ ] out so what do we have time
we're at 50 pretty good huh yeah I mean
the Sylvia Plath references and all this
listen to me man
listen but you know what at the end like
Eric at the end of the day right like
you know when I first met you I'm like
who the [ __ ] is this piece of [ __ ] and I
saw you perform in the Middle East we go
to the Middle East remember in Sebastian
and I met and a single tear came down
your your cheek yeah and I was no porn
and he couldn't make the crowd laugh I
was teasing he was killing you know he
is he never thinks he can do well but
anyway I saw you that years ago with ten
years ago and I saw you go off and I was
like since then I'm really just blessed
to have you in my life
and where you're invited to all of our
life events should we have what should
we have one so she's gonna be everywhere
huh project you have with Pauly Shore
congratulations on that he's gonna do
YouTube video with Pauly Pauly has come
up to me three times I know I did it I
nobody's come up to me three times as if
we haven't had the conversation already
because he's afraid he's afraid that he
can't get you know he called me on the
called me yeah all right first of all I
was in a parking lot and he like was
trying to act like he was mad about him
dying up here yeah he was like you know
and I said Pauly you're not just good of
an actor yeah yeah yeah I know you liked
his show stop yeah so need to tell me
about the thing then yeah he emailed me
I said that's great dude I'll do it I
hit up Bobby okay Bobby you tell me
about this thing and he goes you have to
do it you look politically happy but I
still think it's funny with all the
people that are team ORS in it it's good
do you do what he does played a
political game no not is not like he
does it you know I mean this guy's South
Korea over here no but um I see Pauly at
the spa and I'm really getting to the
point where it's like if I see him I'm
gonna avoid him
but he like because he says Chinese
people
in a song so I walk in those Chinese
people the wonderful people in the world
wait and there's all these Koreans
uncomfortable and then he'll walk up to
a cream man he doesn't know and slap him
in the ass
why would he slap him in a it's [ __ ]
crazy she said I go you're gonna get in
trouble because I nodded but in Korea
they'd kill me but here we're in America
did what the [ __ ] he called me one time
this is like a couple years ago to go to
the Gorn Ramsay Iron Chef or whatever
that definitely goes yeah so we're
sitting in like word we're just we're
eating food you know yeah and Polly's
getting his food and he goes over to
Gordon Ramsay he's not supposed to do
this yeah yeah he's like Gordie Gordie
yeah yeah this isn't cooked right you
know look at the camera and I go you
invited Pauly Shore you thought he was
gonna sit down and have a pleasant meal
yeah like come on man um can I tell you
the most embarrassing thing I ever saw
him do what's that
we're in San Diego and we're at Jamba
Juice this is the old this is when juice
like there was only Jamba Juice oh yeah
they didn't have all the fancy fancy
good [ __ ] now right but now it was Jamba
Juice so there was a line out the door
and he just cuts to the front right I'm
Polly sure I did any cuts and they
[ __ ] served them well I waited in
line actually anyone can do that
what listen I say it's all about
attitude I see women do this all the
time to like just you ever been
someplace and you should cut some cut in
line I know people there are people that
just do that yeah you know what yeah
people like me go no no no oh dude I
mean like you try to cut you know you
know me I'm in lunch you try to cut in
front of me I'm sure excuse me I'm gonna
have to go you're not or I'm gonna call
the police